this year I give a talk on on computer
vision we've focused on deep learning
based computer vision applications just
to first
give an idea of how you know big
creatures deep learning has become in
many computer vision applications
essentially that's that's in the last
three four years it's a big gap in in
performance in quality so for many
applications you actually if you're
willing to sacrifice the speed of
processing you can you can deliver
typically much improved performance for
application so these are examples that I
didn't do in Mathematica that other
people have done in their own software
but this is a case of for self-driving
cars where you you just annotate every
pixel in the image and say that it's a
car that it's a road building and
whatnot it's not that it was impossible
to do face detection before you can do
that in Mathematica and it's fast but if
you do it with deep learning technique
more recently you will get better
performance in terms of quality so of
course this is a another example that it
should be should be pretty aware of
which is for recognition and this is our
own image identify that recognize this
bond beam upon vina correctly as this
type of tools but they are in computer
vision they're also some so I'm ready
I'm ready
puzzling results really that's for
example this is an application about
deaf estimation from a single image so
we take just one picture and the
algorithm is able to recover the Deaf
the normals in the scene and also do
segmentation or at what so and this is
from one image only so the the fact that
based on training data the algorithm is
able to you know find its representation
and achieve this type of very hard task
is pretty impressive and
this is the last example I want to show
I apologize for the image quality but
this is what deep learning algorithm can
do to linearly go from this bedroom to
that bedroom to this bedroom here so
this is the features that are the the
picture representation that are run by
the network and you just do linear you
know blending of the features of this
image and this image and this is what
you find here I find this rather
phenomenal there's no possible images
one of size 100 by 100 and there's atoms
universe and yet the deep Learning
Network manages to you know make it
linear so you see here this is a bedroom
with a TV and it gets transformed into
into a window and and there's non-singer
of this image that clearly is not a
potential bedroom so in this talk we not
going to work on this application but
instead we'll show some of the other
ones and also give an intuition of how
you should develop your own applications
based on deep learning for computer
vision so first that might be a repeat
for those of you who have attended over
deep learning presentations but anyway
some of you will might learn a few
things
this networks is essentially a pipeline
of layers and each layer come takes
inputs compute something and pass it
along to the next step so this is the
classical example that is in the
documentation everywhere it's used for
here for classification tasks it takes
as inputs images and gets output label
airplane automobile whatnot but what I
would like you to better understand is
how it works
so
you see this is the pipeline of
operation the image goes to convolution
layer them I mean all these layers other
and towards the app you have features
that have been learned and these
features are just able to linearly
classify your data so if you look at a
DC cat at this tree here and see what
they do and hopefully that gives you a
feel of what's going on in this network
so this is I just have to do this tree
convolution followed by ramp followed by
a pulling so what will go on when an
image is going through that so let's
first look at this one convolution so
you see that it has 20 output channels
and the channel size is 5 by 5 and so it
takes as input 3 because I have three
channels RGB and then 32 by 32 and gets
the 'south food 20 by 28 by 28 so
actually and this is my toad that I
resize to 32 by 32 so this network don't
take as input an image this is a
misconception what they take as input is
a volume so this is what what the
network is starting with so RGB is being
processed together so you have a stack
of three channels here as input and this
is what we had seen in the network these
are the prompt some parameters for
inside the convolution layer and you see
that after essentially you go through
that layer you will have an output which
is just the result of making a
convolution of the the trading volume
with each of the 20 kernel and adding
the bias so after your image has been
through that that first convolutional
layer it looks like that so these are
the features that will carry on in your
net
so that that's then the dimension that
we expects and after these so you can
think about that as some type of
template matching so each of these 20
channels they can fire if you have
something that looks like an edge little
circle or things like that and after
these you have a step with which it
introduces a non-linearity when you
combine this this input so typically you
use a ramp so if it's negative nothing
if it's positive you let it go so it's
like a switch so that means that you
have these templates maybe the fire
maybe the dots and this type of switch
allow you to decide how to group them so
as you go across the network at some
points maybe a car is something that has
two round circles in the France and and
not rectangle on the left or something
like that so the last operation that
I've not showed is is pulling which
consists in essentially shrinking and
reducing the resolution so the the
underlying trick is that essentially
that feed is differentiable computing so
you assemble these little blobs and in
order for it to be trainable you need to
be able to know if I change a little the
parameters how is it going to affect my
output and so the key is that each of
this layer you need to be able to apply
the chain rule so that in a single
evaluation through the network you can
compute your forwards activations as
well as compute the gradients for each
layer so in only one evaluation of the
network you compute both the output as
well as the radians that go from the
output to the input so this is this is
you know all these layers you need that
su surgery we cannot train efficiently
so the key when you do the plumbing is
that essentially
you try to become this artist and I use
this well because it requires some
mileage to do it well you need to design
a network so that so that you kind of
see that the gradients are going to are
going to be well propagating backwards
so that you can you can compute this
efficiently and therefore you can use
the simple optimization technique based
on stochastic gradient descent which is
I am asking for trouble let me clear all
right so and then you have these
millions of parameters in your network
and all you do is essentially this okay
you start from initial condition and you
just go down down down until you reach a
local minima so if you have a worked on
optimization here you have problems with
100 million parameters so it's very
tricky to train properly and that's
where the skill come into play for
example well in this case if I change
the parameter alpha of my gradient
descent I I can converge faster but if I
make it too big then I dive it right so
and this is you know very easy function
imagine that in a in a space with 100
million parameters so that that's that's
it for what I wanted to convey you give
some intuition about the network so now
let's look at how you would change your
mind frame and stop working on your
problems using the planning so let's
look at this Panda and it's a panda okay
but what image is not if I can do it you
can say okay what if this panda where
food and give me the 10 most or and give
me the probability so you know if you do
that obviously you get an answer but
yeah
know that that's that the probability is
resolute so there's no there's no
problem here now if I have this new
panda that looks pretty much the same as
the other one but it's a panda but now
if I if I ask for foods then then our
network thinks it's ninety percent
confident that this Panda is a pastry so
you know this is a classifier so there's
nothing really fantastic about this
result you don't need a deep deep
network to to do that but it's just that
they can be fooled so how do you make
this fooling thing happen so if you do
it you know traditionally you define an
objective function that takes your input
image adds a little Delta to it then you
pass it through image identify you as
for the top probability that is food and
what if the parameters are too big you
just do penalty because you want a
little change and then you you maximize
this okay so so this is the way
typically you would you do that before
so if you do that you take like the the
big machine from the company you spend
three four days full-time on with eight
channels and 20 gigabytes memory and you
got the Panda up alternatively you can
use you can design your little network
like like this one so let me explain
what I'm doing here this network has
input as the image as inputs it has also
another input which is the what is my my
term get Delta so I want small Delta so
this is another input and also the last
in I also give the the probability I
want so here I would say that I want
this output probability to be very close
from my pastry so what's going on in
this network I take the input I add a
little Delta I pass it through
imaginative file network and then gets
the output class
and so this gets optimized at the same
time I also wants Delta to be little
very small so this is another loss that
I have and and that's it I optimize this
and you know the output will be this is
my output of the network as well so if
you do that you don't need to spend
three days and 20 gigabytes of memory it
spread you're pretty much done in one
minute on your laptop that requires so
and why because you all of these little
steps of differentiable so essentially
you yeah you have all these parameters
but that converges super quickly so okay
so that that was somehow introduction
now I want to debunk a few meats as well
for that so you hear that yeah you need
to design your network is this video you
need some artistic skills for that then
you need the big data and you need a
massive GPU to do your work it's not
necessarily true for example for an
architecture if you don't know what
you're doing then just take something
that is there and that would work for
you most probably so we have Zhu Xin we
will have zoos in Mathematica there was
many of your models you can find and if
you really need you make some adjustment
to it but you don't don't necessarily
try to find something you know don't
boil the deaf star if you don't start
right just stop playing with it now in
terms of data yeah you do need data but
if you don't have a lot what you should
do is start from a free trade model and
you know just make a little change to it
based on your data so you start from a
MIDI notify and you give new training
data and you change it a bit so it's
work for your data you can also
synthesize new samples so and even if
you have one computer with a good single
NVIDIA GPU you can do a lot already and
if it at some point you need more you
can go for the big
okay so a parent of them is keeping that
so this is something that I think was
already mentioned but this is if you if
you just want to use image identify
features if feature extracts will do
that and give your panda gives you some
of the features and this allows you to
do out of core this is completely out of
course so you have here some some URL of
the top 100 monuments I've not even
looked at the picture of to tell you the
truth and then you extract the features
for from image identify and you know
once you you have it you just if you
want to see what's going on with the
world from Alfie Fanta we all know this
is the top five results again it's very
simple thing and I've not looked at the
images so I'm just claiming you know
it's just how you would just how you
would use like is there for you imagine
on suffice features so now let's work on
an application which is the quality
estimation of an image so these are our
data set where people are rating images
and the safe is good or bad and they
give a score one is very bad and 100 is
excellent so you have like a thousand
image a few thousand ratings so this is
of the type of images you have for
example that animal here has a rating of
37 standard deviation of 17 which is
pretty high and while the category is
full so you have this and the goal is to
have the computer learn how to produce
this number here all right so here what
I'm going to do is I will start from a
image intensifier type of model I think
I won't have time to run it to any
details I will just make changes to this
very small changes I'm just going to
drop this last layer and I'm going to
replace this I keep all this and I just
replace these two layer
and so that these new layers will be
adapted to my problem so this is what I
will do if I put this - my plan de I get
2048 features and a replace replace the
last a year by by a new layer on my own
this little and net so there's I want to
mention here I don't have a lot of data
so I do some determination by so I'm
kind of doing some random dropping
inside my image to get more data for
free so I take some small portions and
that allows me pretty much to inflate as
much as I want my data sets we've got
some prime so in the end I have these
features for each image of scores and
and our set of features for each prop
once you know elevate freak is to be
balanced yo-yo training sets so I have I
have training set which is big dis
balanced here so I'll just make it like
that and compute training testing sets
skipping this all right and now I'm
going to train that alright so I I'm
taking this massive network that has
been trade on on massive computers for 4
weeks and I just changed the end so it's
pretty quick and alright so then you
know you can use it you you see that
it's not performing great but at the
same time the standard deviations are so
high in this data set that it's fine
excellent images are never bad mostly
excellent or good for example so you
know then you just in the end let me let
me move on so I have time to show you a
bit applications I have in mind in the
end I can I have this feature so now I
can use predict on my features and
help still running alright okay so you
know Freddie's found the pretty so I
found ourselves a need for a stronger
realization and let me see if that was
already pre computed with receive some
time okay so this is the results here so
you know the correlation coefficient is
okay I mean 65 and and this is what it
should be and this is what we have so if
ideally will be on the diagonal so
that's we are doing kind of okay around
this area
Centauri all right so this is how you
would then when you have an image 90 and
what you do you extract the features
that you have fine-tunes and they are
using as input the features from image
identify type right and I do that on 20
crops and I take the average so since
I'm running out of time I'll just doing
to crop I did mention that it was now
the speedo is not you know a sense of
this type of application alright so 53
for this picture of Superman's house
alright so I have I have a few minutes
left for my last application which is
action recognition from video so it's
kind of a very small data set it's a 1
101 type of actions there's about 13
thousand videos 200 images per video so
if this is one of them
so it's funny to look at videos that all
right so this is one video for you you
this is the new activity okay so this
type of thing we want to so let me point
out this is a toy you know in a few
years we won't do action recognition
like that because you have thousands of
objects you have even more thousands of
ways to interact with them so you cannot
do a class for each of them but anyway
this is this paper you take a sequence
video sequence you have one classifier
using a single image and this is some
type of image isn't if I again and here
you have also another classifier this
this one encodes temporal information
and this is based on optical flow and
then you combine them together
I will I won't show you what optical
flow looks like but hopefully you have
you have an idea you know this is it
gives a vector field so that tells you
that that point here on the next image
is actually there so this is encoding
the motion instead of using the paper
we're using this these Google Nets
innovation one why because it's more
modern so it works better it's less
memory so it's all good and I do out of
cop training so my training set is
composed of a list of files and list of
classes there's almost two million
images for training seven hundred
thousand for testing so this is not for
your laptop or not mine for sure and you
know so if you take a run pass a random
image through that I did not know it
will do that but I'm not unhappy about
it so the random image is me Terry Perry
alright so but this is this is what I
want you to to see this is like tricks
our first I did that trace options first
I said that use GPU number one that's
why if you have a machine with several
GPUs you can run several training at the
same time just change your GPU number
then here I use stochastic I do some
type of fine-tuning where I take I start
from this image identified Network and
what I do I put a ray
for the gradient descent which is very
little and that will mean that I'm going
to change my network but not too much
ideally I would prefer to keep it frozen
but we cannot do it in version 11 so
just little changes a lot and this
function option here tells that every
two hours you need to save whatever best
model you have so far I mean that'll be
pretty you take to not do that right
else you would spend days and maybe
waste your work waiting for results not
no one would maybe do them maybe so do
that and then you know this is how it
will it's looking like after you don't
training it so no this is the batch so
the date training data and this is the
validation pretty nice okay and okay oh
it's right all right all right so now I
have my my special net so now the
temporal net from the optical flow well
I'm running out of time for the delivery
but I was running out of computer time
for the training so let me tell you bits
what I'm just jumping on possible issues
that I have encountered a particular
text time so you need to pre-compute
that okay
so and you need to save as images
because out of common you works with
images and it has a big it takes it has
a big footprints each image which you
store the optical floors are really 32
you know in the end it will you will
arrive here with more than 17 terabytes
of data okay so that's that's way too
much if on top of that your your red
partition where data is stored is
starting to crash then you have to do
something like read use of this data and
so forth so this actually this happened
to me so I just had enough enough one
model I have where's my model this is
this is the result of a snapshot that
Ned train gave me a few hours ago I made
the mistake of not doing checkpointing
all right
so I that stuff has been running for 20
hours and I have only one model if I
don't checkpointing every 12 worse I
will not be like I am now but the thing
is that this model I tried it it's no
good yet because it has not trained
enough okay so this is pretty much what
would it be left to do after this it
will be just be to feel the spatial and
temporal Nets but as I mentioned I run
into hardware problems and other things
so thank you these are just a kind of a
little list of features that I would
love to see soon in a machine learning
people I'm sure we are going to
implement that very quickly that will
help with a computer vision applications
when you develop your own so I see the
next picture must be getting ready if
you have a few questions I'll be happy
to take them
while we transition
[Applause]